[Musica]
ragazze e ragazzi sono contentissimo di
essere qui buongiorno ringrazio
l'organizzazione per avermi invitato
sono molto contento ma anche molto molto
emozionato
vorrei correggere quello che hanno detto
lì perché una vergogna non hanno fatto
oltre tre anni della mia vita in giro
per il mondo perché altrimenti sarebbe
una cosa molto molto breve e purtroppo
con quando mi ha invitato il mio ha
contattato raccontare oltre per anni
meravigliosi della mia vita in giro per
il mondo in soli 15 minuti è una cosa
per me impossibile quindi cercherò di
regalarvi qualche emozione in questi
pochi minuti da cosa è nata la passione
per la vela e va a vela da poco tempo
visto per una seconda volta nel 2007 il
film waterworld con kevin costner è la
prima volta non piacque la seconda fu
ovviamente sulla hbo p nome ore mi
innamorai perché sono un passionale
della vita e in campeggio dove lavoro a
grado e fanno i corsi di vela
dopo due giorni aveva visto il film
pezzi di corse di catamarano terminato
dopo qualche altro giorno ne acquista in
un catamarano da spiaggia ma veramente
poco solo due mezze stagioni
perché una tromba d'aria me lo distrusse
allora un mio amico mi disse sottovoce
prenditi la barca a vela prenditi la
verve caverà vedrai vedrai che
soddisfazioni
allora mi questa è una barca a vela e
tutti coloro secondo me che usano una
vera che sia un tight una barchetta un
surf il giro del mondo il sogno del
cassetto di tutti e vi devo dire che
fare il giro del mondo in barca a vela
non era assolutamente un assolutamente
una cosa da superman ma bensì alla
portata di tutti di tutti quanti
basta provarci bisogna bisogna
affrontare non superare e sconfiggere
superare le paure che stanno nella
nostra mente quando comincia ad
affrontarne vedi che di là c'é la vita è
la vita è bellissima e nel 2011
siccome mi piace sono passionale mi
piace a dai nel 2011 fece il corso di
vela oceanica insieme a giovanni soldini
e vittorio malingri
a cavallo tra novembre e dicembre 2011
in circa un mesetto da gibilterra
canarie che noi caraibi guadalupe fu
un'esperienza talmente bella bellissima
stavo così bene mi sentivo uno spirito
che sarei andato avanti fino alla morte
e saremo molto contento e allora questa
esperienza mi ha lasciato veramente
quasi un embolo nel cervello ed è stata
anche un periodo in cui cominciava
andare fuori giri era tutto troppo la
mia vita era tanto lavoro tanto stress
tante cose allora dovevo trovare una
soluzione per la mia salute e ho pensato
che il giro del mondo poteva essere un
abuso una buona cura invece è stata
un'eccellente un eccellente medicina
allora nel 2012 di acquistare una barca
e mi ci vuole un anno per la
preparazione e per organizzare le rotte
tutte queste cose qui è all'incirca sei
anni fa 8 giugno 2013 parti per il mio
giro del mondo in due mesi e due mesi
prima della mia partenza due mesi dopo
furono uno dei periodi più duri più
difficili della mia vita perché lasciare
lavoro gli amici i sentimenti e per
un'avventura che non sai cosa sarà
e stata veramente molto molto duro però
bisogna lasciare quella cosa che noi
chiamiamo sicurezze per poter vivere la
vita e questo è stato un periodo
veramente molto molto difficile perché
affrontare un viaggio così in giro per
il mondo e non sai come andrà a finire è
stata veramente molto molto difficile
poi le isole i navigatori i popoli di
tutto il mondo che mi hanno amato e li
ho amati e stata un'avventura veramente
molto molto bella e la mia e mi biagio
lo divido in due parti grado nuova
zelanda nuova zelanda grado e nella
prima parte degli azzurri ho avuto ogni
giorno paura a volte poca volte tanta
quando il mare s'ingrossava cominciavo
sia tramare anch'io verratti un po di
angoscia ma la paura in tante cose
in questa cosa qui è fondamentale perché
la paura ti tiene di tiene sveglio la la
paura ti tiene vivo e ti fa sopravvivere
mentre la seconda parte del mio viaggio
poche verni sentiva così sicuro molto
più sicuro che poche volte ho avuto ho
avuto paura e la paura delle paure più
grosse
mi è successa nel mar dei caraibi
navigazione tra la martinica e a parma
ma prima di attraversare il canale di
panama per raggiungere quel meraviglioso
oceano che si chiama oceano pacifico e a
metà percorso
allargo 100 miglia a largo della
colombia del venezuela c'era un giorno e
mezzo di burrasca e primo giorno stato
abbastanza forte e la mia barchetta dico
barchetta perché era lunga solamente
dieci metri 10 metri veramente piccola
robben fatta ben costruita e e secondo
giorno ero di guardia eravamo in tre a
bordo che facevamo tre ore di guardia e
6 di riposo euro riguarda il mattino e
lì ho scoperto che dio c'è e aumentato
tante volte ma non il dio per il punto
di vista che sta nelle chiese nelle
moschee o tutti gli altri parte altri
posti ma il dio che sta dentro di te
quello che se fai del bene avrei del
bene se fai del male non avrai tanto
bene e se non mi fossi voltato euro di
guardia se come fosse voltata questo era
penso non sarei qui
anche se ero legato salvagente tutte
queste cosette un certo punto mi sono
voltato c'era un onda incrociata
pensando che in quella burrasca lì le
onde avevano all'incirca dai 4 ai 6
metri una barchetta di 10 metri
ovviamente poco come mi sono voltato e
ho visto questa montagna blu d'acqua
non so quanto possa alta 6 8 10 12 metri
non lo so non frazioni di secondo mi
sono aggrappato il wing spiantato edili
per terra è arrivata quest onda e mi ha
capovolto sommerso la barca e subito
dopo insomma sarà analizzata e lì
insomma addio si è fatto vedere per la
prima volta e gli ostacoli altri
ostacoli per esempio risalendo
l'app l'antico del sud e anche qui di
omessa fa mi ha aiutato c'era un ragazzo
stavamo facendo
la traversata da città del capo i
caraibi oltre 6000 miglia oltre 10.000
km e vicino a dar senso rayman subito
dopo sant'elena c'era andrea un ragazzo
bravissimo di savona a poche miglia da
dall'isolotto che dobbiamo andare a
visitare una settimana e un certo punto
mi dice guarda antonio vado riposare by
andrea ti chiamo dopo altri 5 minuti in
forno di far tardi qualcosa di forte chi
sta male e e niente poi ritorna nella
sua cabina torna fuori mi dice che non
dottor allora ho avuto anche
l'esperienza di lanciare may day may day
e ha senso nile anglosassoni inglese nel
giro di dieci minuti sono venuti a bordo
con un gommone velocissimo cinque di
loro per cui un dottore e dopo venti
minuti era già in ospedale colica renale
passata preferisco sempre navigare 23
persone per dei semplici motivi 1 per la
sicurezza perché se andrea fosse stato
in salita in mezzo all'oceano non so
cosa sarebbe successo
e se non fossimo stati vicino a un'isola
avrei dovuto lanciare l'allarme
internazionale e quando passava qualche
nave qualcuno l'avrebbe ripresa ma
cercate di fare qualcosa e poi anche
navigare con più persone per condividere
le emozioni che per mare e ce ne sono
tantissimi stai giorni mesi a guardare
il mare perché il mare è sempre e sempre
diverso per i navigatori che ho trovato
sono stati nell'oceano pacifico pare che
sono poche le persone che arrivano fin
da quando arrivi lì e tranne guidatori
c'e tantissima solidarietà anche perché
si capisce le difficoltà che si che si
fanno per raggiungere quei post quei
posti
calcolando che il sud pacifico
all'incirca una superficie quadrata
quasi quanto la terra ed è veramente le
distanze tra le isole sono veramente di
giorni e settimane e trovare anche
attrezzature se qualche problema a bordo
non è facile e non solamente chi naviga
24 su 24
molti giorni settimana si rende conto
come a bordo a bordo ogni giorno si
rompe qualcosa o la radio la sentina o
le vele c'è sempre qualche problemino e
questo viaggio è stato bellissimo lo
sono partito perché hanno dato fuori
giri
come dicevo prima e lì mi sono reso
conto in 3 anni 2 mesi e 15 giorni della
mia vita non ho mai avuto la tosse e
raffreddore mal di testa mal di denti
neanche i brufoli nomi sono cresciuti lì
mi sono reso conto che l'essere umano è
entrato nella sua dimensione
perché io credo avendo avuto anche la
fortuna di pensare molto avuto avendo
avuto il tempo è una cosa preziosissima
e lì mi sono reso conto si l'essere
umano non è fatto per quello che stiamo
facendo ora
io lo chiamo un progresso regresso
infatti quando siamo
sono rientrato dal mio giro allo stretto
di gibilterra lì mi sono detto ecco di
antonio ritornato nella centrifuga
europea è una cosa molto importante è
anche brutta mentre stava facendo la
traversata
eravamo in tre dell'oceano indiano
dall'australia fino alle mauritius è
lunga circa 2.500 km 4.500 va ad hoc
2.500 milia quasi 5.000 chilometri e
quello che vi sto per raccontare se non
fosse la non ci crederete al giorno
d'oggi si fa tanta pubblicità sembra che
sia una moda parlare di questa bara di
questa plastica di queste isole di
plastica e lì per oltre 3 quasi tremila
chilometri ogni 40 70 metri in
continuazione e c'era plastica borsette
pantofole e bambole di tutto e di tutta
una cosa veramente veramente molto molto
brutta e la situazione dal mio punto di
vista per quello che ha avuto la fortuna
di vedere non solo in questo viaggio ma
anche in altri è veramente veramente
triste veramente drammatica poi
metabolizzando dopo un po di tempo e mi
sono accorto che l'oceano indiano e
tutto costeggiato da paesi del terzo
come l'africa l'india madagascar
thailandia indonesia e vola e lì insomma
l'attenzione per i mondi se queste cose
qui non è non c'è molta attenzione la
situazione veramente veramente triste e
poi da mauritius
mi sono trovato da solo a fare una
traversata delle mauritius fino al
sudafrica quasi duemila quasi 2.000
miglia e due settimane di navigazione e
subito aveva trovato solo per la prima
volta ed è stata un'esperienza
fantastica bellissima per me stesso
perché dopo 3 4 giorni senza condizioni
da parte di nessuno
cosa che a terra non abbiamo la
possibilità perché non è che siamo due
tre settimane senza vedere nessuno senza
parlare senza vedere la televisione
solamente con la banca a cui vuoi bene e
nel male il vento che ti muovi ti muove
santis posti per distanze enormi senza
inquinare e pensare che in mezzo agli
oceani ci sono miliardi e miliardi di
uccelli di tutte le specie grandi anche
piccolini così che mi sono venuti tanti
anche a bordo è stato molto importante
perché la mia mente dopo 34 giorni ha
cominciato a pensare in maniera diversa
e pensavo se a terra avessi dice
alberghi dieci automobili 10 milioni di
euro sarebbero state solamente elementi
oggetti che avrebbero portato via il
tempo della mia vita mi avrebbero creato
nemici problemi non dormire la notte e
di stato con l'essenziale con pochissimo
a parti costa della barca con di
mangiare e stata un'esperienza veramente
bellissima e mi sono detto io un giorno
voglio ritornare in questa in questa
dimensione e di la mente mira cominciato
a cambiare a vedere le cose in maniera
diversa è stato personalmente
un'esperienza importante
un altro un altro un'altra cosa che
voglio raccontare e di jonathan unioni
conio zelandese ed i 35 anni che ho
avuto la fortuna di conoscere a tahiti
lui era un istruttore skydiving quelli
che si lanciano paracadute tutta la rete
tra queste cose qui ha avuto un
incidente ha perso l'uso delle gambe e
lui è un navigatore
oceanico che va in giro per il mondo con
la sua barchetta di soli 9 metri in
metallo ed è una persona straordinaria
noi ci facciamo mille paranoie mille
problemi su tante cose e vedeva una
persona conoscere una persona così dove
sono stato diverse volte ospite a casa
sua in nuova zelanda è stata veramente
molto molto interessante molto bello una
cosa tutti mi chiedono quasi del posto
più bello in cui sono stato per me non
c'è almeno un importante cosa avevo cosa
maggio dove sono ma le persone che mi
stanno accanto e lì è stato e conoscere
una persona come giornata è stata
veramente una cosa molto molto profonda
e niente adesso voglio augurarmi dirvi
buon vento e che voi lo diciate a me
perché tra due settimane parto volo e
vado trasferirmi io mi auguro per tutta
la vita il più a lungo possibile in sud
pacifico in polinesia francese isole
salomon fisi tutti questi posti molti
qui
insomma vi ringrazio buon vento anche a
voi
grazie grazie di tutto
[Applauso]